she should be removed from from the
house take a look at this
they're coming for our guns and for our
civil rights are they not
they're not but okay
oh of course they are as a matter of
fact stacy abrams who is running for
governor for the second time in georgia
and her announcement speech after she
said that she would pursue aggressive
vaccinations of georgian
she the next thing she talked about was
grabbing people's guns she hates
georgia's second amendment rights she
she wants to stop constitutional carry
which is exactly what our state
legislators and our governors should be
pursuing right now they should be
passing it and signing it into law
but yeah no democrats they hate our
second amendment because ultimately the
truth is it's our second amendment
rights our right to bear arms that
protect americans and give us the
ability to defend ourselves from a
tyrannical government now remember there
are no prominent democrats suggesting
getting rid of the second amendment